aus reinhardts sie haben auch beklagt
das ist jetzt am anfang diese
konzentration auf die krankenhäuser gab
und eben nicht auf die seniorenheime und
auf die hausärzte und die praxen der
ärzte dann denken sie wird sich daran
etwas ändern und wie schnell muss sich
was ändern masken desinfektionsmittel
shops kleider das ist ein ganz leidiges
thema muss man wirklich sagen ist dieser
erste schutzwall ja auch keiner der
funktioniert wahrscheinlich wieder sehen
können an den heimen in denen das jetzt
einbricht und wenn dann das virus sich
in einem so geschlossenen bereich wie
einem altenwohnheim eingenistet hat oder
dort ausbricht dann ist es noch viel
schlimmer als wenn es sozusagen irgendwo
sporadisch wäre das heißt dass der
vorteil der unter umständen darin
besteht dass menschen jedenfalls in
dieser hinsicht der vorteil unter sich
wohnen so dass man versuchen könne sie
am block zu schützen wird an dieser
stelle plötzlich zu einem ganz großen
nachteil wenn erst einmal einmal so
einer infektion in einem in einer
solchen einrichtung ist oder auch ein
krankenhaus ist und insofern muss man
sagen ist dagegen der pflege in der
altenpflege vor allen dingen auch in der
monaten alten pflege der mangel an
schutzmasken und schutzkleidung hat ganz
fatal gefallen muss uns helfen sie
kennen die diskussion wann gibt es
endlich genug schutz mit also wenn die
decke zu kurz ist wo soll man sie
hinziehen dann gibt es genug masken gibt
es genug desinfektionsmittel sind ja
also ich bin ja ganz engen austausch
auch mit meinem kollegen
bundesgesundheitsministerin spanier
hatte sollte aber gut
ja ja ja der hat ja die verantwortung
auch dafür gemeinsam mit den ländern und
mit vielen anderen die zusammenarbeit
nachmittag mit ihm telefoniert und er
sagte mir es ist ja jetzt so dass das
bundesgesundheitsministerium seit zwei
wochen einen beschaffung starb hat
zusammen mit dem auswärtigen amt um auch
aus dem ausland schutzkleidung und
masken zu bekommen und mit dem
finanzministerium was die finanziellen
möglichkeiten dafür auch schafft weil
vieles jetzt über vorkasse gehen muss es
sind knapp 40 millionen masken in den
letzten zwei wochen beschafft worden
die werden jetzt über die länder
verteilt es wird sukzessive auch weiter
jetzt beschafft auch beatmungsgeräte
schutzkleidung das muss jetzt verteilt
werden mir als seine ministerin die auch
die kinder- und jugendeinrichtungen
diesen hohen pflegeheime im blick hat
ist natürlich genauso wichtig dass es
eben nicht nur an die krankenhäuser geht
sondern dass wir auch dort unterstützen
wo die kleineren 1
richtung sind und das ist jetzt ganz
wichtig dass das was auf bundesebene
beschafft wird die an die länder
weitergegeben wird was passiert und sage
länder das dann entsprechend auch
verteilen an die kleineren einrichtungen
das ist jetzt die aufgabe und das wird
aber sukzessive auch besser es ist jetzt
sehr sehr viel beschworen und wird auch
in den nächsten tagen auch weiter
intensiv beschaffen was empfehlen sie
frau urlaub menschen die sagen ich hole
meine mama die oma nach hause ich möchte
sie nicht mehr in dem heim lassen
sondern ich will sie nach hause holen
unter diesen bedingungen
es ist nicht jedes sagen wie das in
erkelenz es gibt viele gute aber es gibt
auch welche die kämpfen
also es gibt sehr viele gute heime und
wir wissen auch allen ist kein geheimnis
es gibt auch sehr problematischer heime
und wenn ich so ein problematisches hall
mettin lernte meine mutter in so einem
haus ich würde sie auf jeden fall nach
hause nehmen weil unter diesen umständen
die wir jetzt haben das pflegepersonal
hat keine schutzkleidung es hat keine
masken
wir haben zu wenig fachkräfte es gibt es
arbeiten leute die der deutschen sprache
nicht mächtig sind die die anweisungen
nicht verständigen hygienevorschriften
nicht verstehen
die teilweise vom robert-koch-institut
diese vorlagen gar nicht lesen können
ich finde schon dass heime sehr
problematisch sind unter diesen
umständen und wenn sich jemand leisten
kann
bitte sofort nach hause holen glauben
sie herein hat dass wir tatsächlich eben
diese heime herausfinden
müssen die tatsächlich eben auch zu
wenig tun können für die alten oder
sagen sie
grosso modo sind die deutschen
altenheime gute heime und plädieren
deshalb dafür dass man sie sogar noch
mehr in heime geben sondern wenigstens
waren sie so zäh glaube dass die auf
jeden fall
seit langem schwierigkeiten haben was
die pflege angeht
und ich glaube dass diese
schwierigkeiten jetzt natürlich zu
nehmen weil gar keinen besuch mehr
stattfinden darf der vielleicht ein
bisschen dazu beigetragen hat matthias
abzumildern also wird jetzt alles an
knapp und pflegepersonal hängen dass es
so bleibt so deshalb sind die trotzdem
im verhältnis im internationalen
vergleich ziemlich gut
ich betreue solche heime auch als
hausarzt das funktioniert ganz
anständigen trotzdem ist es schwer und
ich glaube dass es die tatsache dass
alte menschen bei uns jedenfalls mehr
als zum beispiel in spanien oder italien
in solchen situationen leben bisher ein
grund dafür war dass die ältere
bevölkerung uns bei uns nicht so häufig
koeffizient war wie dass wir insofern
etwas weniger karriere vorläufig können
und das müssen wir in irgendeiner form
jetzt nutzen dazu hätten wir aber auch
schon vor 14 tagen oder drei wochen nur
noch vier wochen
genau an dieser stelle etwas tun müssen
über den schutzmasken kiefer bin ich
guter hoffnung ja aber das schon 14 tage
oder eine woche und guter hoffnung dass
das irgendwie vorangeht
ich habe festgestellt haben aber eine
zentrale beschaffungsstelle versucht
weltweit was zu kaufen ich habe eine
unternehmen in ostwestfalen ein
autozulieferer der mir ein prototyp zur
dazu kommen lassen einer fb2 maske die
nachgebaut worden ist ein unternehmen
was sonst fliesst material in autos
eingebaut
sie haben das in ihrem labor nach
getestet und haben die gleichen test
werte wie die eigentlichen medizinische
schutzmasken
das habe ich dem bmg übergeben vor 14
tagen ministerin für gesundheit
entschuldigung
danke die haben dann dass er schnell
weitergeleitet an das bundesministerium
für oder dieses bundesamt für
arzneimittel und medizinprodukte das
befahren und die haben eine
ausnahmegenehmigung erteilt dass dieses
deutsche unternehmen masken produzieren
darf 15 millionen zunächst in der woche
dann sind sie die maske
die losgeworden denn die kommen aus der
autoindustrie und die haben keinen
distributionswege ins gesundheitswesen
hat dass die bundesministerin für
gesundheit nichts gegen sparen dann aber
nicht richtig schnell geholfen mich ab
heute nochmal nachgefahren unternehmen
geholfen hat dann das landesliste in
düsseldorf die haben bis juni 30
millionen masken gekauft innerhalb von
zwei stunden geht jetzt auch genau dass
man zu so dass man das muss ich glaube
man muss kein beschaffungsseite zentrale
beschaffung machen die versucht in kenia
irgendwas zu kaufen sondern muss
deutsche industrie anregen das betrifft
die tests die wir auch fahren müssen
ganz genau so zu produzieren dass ist ja
generell guter einwand dass vielleicht
auch diese krise dazu führt man darüber
nachzudenken ob einige produkte ich auch
generell in der wir in deutschland
produzieren will
ich bin sowieso aber ich auch gerne
einmal vor immer wenn sie mir erlauben
das sehr sehr viel kritisches gesagt und
das ist auch sicher an vielen stellen
berechtigt aber ich für einmal sagen wir
haben seit beginn dieser legislatur
gemeinsam mit ihren sparen gemeinsam mit
hubertus heil und mein ministerium haben
wir ja die konzertierte aktion pflege
gestartet mit ganz vielen partnern in
der pflege wir haben im letzten jahr
auch ein wichtiges gesetz beschlossen
zur verbesserung der löhne in der pflege
das wird jetzt alles gemacht wir machen
gerade eine große ausbildungskampagne
die nicht nur läuft im sinne von wie
gewinnt man menschen dafür sondern wie
bezahlt man sie auch besser seit anfang
des jahres haben wir endlich
deutschlandweit kein schulgeld mehr
endlich eine ausbildungsvergütung mit
über 1000 euro anfangs
ausbildungsvergütung in der pflege das
sind alles wichtige punkte und ich will
nur sagen ich verstehe all die
praktischen dinge die sie auch berichten
das hören wir auch aber wir sind
intensiv trend und wir sehen in dieser
krise dass die aufwertung der sozialen
berufe die pflege gehört wie wozu auch
viele andere systemrelevante berufe
können dass das ein ganz wichtiges
querschnittsthema es und es sind
meistens die frauen die in diesen
berufen arbeiten und das ist auch etwas
da müssen wir noch weit weit über die
kommenden und jetzt in zeiten hinaus
darüber das quartier haben wir hier
schon diskutiert ist
eine petition auch der pflegerinnen und
pfleger endlich etwas an den löhnen zu
tun und eben ab 4000 brutto aufwärts
nachzudenken
frau könig wollte so gerne noch mal zu
ihnen nach erkelenz schauen sie haben
noch betten in ihrem heim frei würden
sie noch dafür plädieren mehr bewohner
aufzunehmen oder sagen sie nee das ist
richtig dass manche heime jetzt einen
aufnahmestopp verhängt also ich muss
jetzt trotzdem einmal ganz schnell
nahmen wir was zu dem vorher bei ihnen
diskutierten themen sagen ich glaube es
ist im moment ganz wenig hilfreich über
löhne oder gehälter zu sprechen oder
mögliche beschaffungsmaßnahmen von oder
interesse gewinnung von interessenten
oder oder
ich finde es sehr schön wenn wir uns
jetzt auf diese hoch komplizierte
situation konzentrieren würden und wenn
wir da ein stück weiter gekommen sind
dann finde ich es sehr wichtig dass man
mal versucht nochmal eine analyse zu
schaffen und genauer hinzugucken weil
viele der probleme die wir jetzt haben
sind hausgemachte probleme wir haben
zwei material gesehen wir sehen es auch
in der personalsituation und die krise
ist aus meiner wahrnehmung an der stelle
echt noch mal ein brennglas was das
ganze deutlicher macht so und deshalb
jetzt vielleicht noch mal auf die
derzeit aktuell schwierige situation
aufnahmestopps sind aus meiner
wahrnehmung eventuell in bestimmten
situationen in denen sich eine
einrichtung befindet notwendig oder
hilfreich das liegt ja auch daran dass
wir sehr viele unterschiedliche
räumliche
und personelle situation im gesamten
bundesrepublik haben unser haus hat zum
beispiel sieben etagen das ist relativ
untypisch wir haben sehr wenig
doppelzimmer da hat man natürlich eine
gute möglichkeit auch gegebenenfalls
isolationsmaßnahmen durchzuführen
von daher grundsätzlich glaube ich dass
in einzelfällen aufnahmestopp angezeigt
ist aber es macht absolut keinen sinn so
was pauschal zu postulieren weil damit
wird das leid von vielen menschen
schlichtweg nur vergrößert und es kann
auch nicht im sinne sein dass menschen
die zu hause nicht mehr versorgt werden
können oder
die krankenhäuser menschen nicht mehr
entlassen können weil das aufnahmestopp
es gibt also an der stelle
es hilft nichts werden immer wieder alle
aufgefordert sehr differenziert und
genau hinzugucken und einzel
entscheidung zu treffen die in den dem
rahmen in dem sie getroffen werden auch
dann richtig sind und helfen würde ihnen
frau königs natürlich wenn sie ihre
bewohner und ihr personal regelmäßig
testen könntest du ja das ist ja auch so
eine diskussion das weiß ich nicht so
genau weil also das kann auch das kann
wieder in bestimmten situationen
hilfreich sein und auch beruhigend sein
auf der anderen seite ich bin ich habe
keinen überblick darüber wie groß die
ressourcen an testmöglichkeiten in der
bundesrepublik im moment sind von daher
man lässt ja auch in den medien häufiger
dass auch da irgendwelche bestehen
deshalb zu regelmäßige testung bei
menschen die keinerlei symptome zeigen
konnten wenn das testmaterial knapp ist
ja vielleicht auch nicht ganz sinnvoll
sein
die zweite den zweiten gedanken ist halt
die halbwertszeit von solchen test
ergebnissen
und damit verbunden wenn ich heute
negativ getestet bin kann das ja
übermorgen bei mir schon wieder ganz
anders aussehen und die gefahren
natürlich dann auch wieder so in einer
sicherheit ist dies eigentlich nicht
gibt im moment man würde sich in einer
sicherheit wiegen die ist gerade nicht
gibt phoenix danke dass sie uns diesen
blick in ihr haus gestattet haben und
wir drücken natürlich die daumen und
wünschen vor allem gesundheit für sie
und ihr altenheim und damit sind wir
noch mal frau gefallen bei der frage
nach diesen aufnahme stopp sven heime
das für sich festlegen muss nicht
trotzdem das argument von phoenix gehört
werden dass es natürlich total wichtig
ist für manche menschen jetzt
ausgerechnet jetzt dringend in eine
professionelle heimat zu kommen
ich glaube dass generell für ganz viele
fragen die diese krise betreffen
pauschale antworten zunehmend nicht mehr
einzugreifen ja das ist ja weil wir
müssen bei allem was wir entscheiden
immer auch die risiken und
nebenwirkungen betrachten wieder so
schön heißt und alles was jetzt
entschieden wird in einer absolutheit
hat natürlich auch nebenwirkungen wir
sehen das nicht nur bei der frage
pauschale aufnahmestopp sondern auch bei
der frage was bedeuten kita und
schulschließungen über einen langen
zeitraum was bedeutet notbetreuung was
bedeuten all diese dinge und wir sehen
dass es eben ein zunehmendes problem
konfliktpotenzial gibt in den familien
bei kindern und jugendlichen bei älteren
menschen bei der frage von häuslicher
gewalt und das sind alles dinge die über
einen zeitablauf ja auch zu nehmen und
deshalb muss das alles gut abgewogen
werden damit man dann auch über die
lange sicht eine sinnvolle entscheidung
trifft und damit sollte dort in den
einrichtungen vor allen dingen anhand
der konkreten lage vor ort bewerten wir
entschieden werden so und dann sind wir
genau bei diesem gedanken der ja auf den
ersten blick verlockend klingt dass man
sich vor allen dingen und besonders um
die hochrisikogruppen kümmert und das
sind nun mal in erster linie kranke und
alte
und diese ideen gibt es irgendwann
irgendwann über eine lockerung dieser
kontaktsperre nachzudenken
und hier ist noch mal eine kleine
zusammenfassung ein begriff macht die
runde
umkehr isolation alte und kranke
menschen sollen nach einer lockerung des
locker uns weiter eingesperrt bleiben
womöglich auf monate hinaus
ich halte viel von dem vorschlag statt
der gesamten bevölkerung gezielt
besonders gefährdete bevölkerungsgruppen
zu isolieren insbesondere ältere und vor
erkrankte denkbar wäre eine
ausgangssperre für personen über 70
jahre
es ist wirklich der richtige zeitpunkt
ältere menschen in quarantäne zu nehmen
alle über 70 jährigen in quarantäne das
ist das einzige was wirklich hilft
menschen die über 65 jahre alt sind und
risikogruppen werden aus dem alltag
heraus genommen und vermeiden weiter
kontakte jüngere die weniger gefährdet
sind werden nach und nach kontrolliert
und wieder in den produktionsprozess
integriert solche strategien müssen in
den nächsten wochen diskutiert werden
robert habeck wir haben gerade boris
palmer zugehört der auch für die zeit
nach der lockerung vorschlägt die
älteren menschen er sagt nun 65 besser
zu schützen das ist natürlich ein
euphemismus am ende geht es darum sie
mehr zu isolieren
ist das in ihren augen möglich ist es
wichtig darüber zu reden dass damit die
jüngeren wieder raus können die alten
rhein müssen oder drin bleiben müssen
ich glaube wir brauchen dringend eine
diskussion über das wie einer anderen
strategien auf ewig halten wir das als
gesellschaft nicht aus wir haben das
über die über die älteren und die
pflegebedürftigen jetzt angerissen vor
gefahr hat zu recht gesagt es gibt
häusliche gewalt depression
wahrscheinlich alkoholismus
scheidungsraten suizidgefahr was einmal
noch dazukommen kann das ist alles
bedenklich aber der vorschlag der
sogenannten umkehr isolation
wir sperren die altenberg davon halte
ich gar nichts ich glaube es geht in die
falsche richtung
es gibt bessere überlegungen alles
kompliziert die abwägungsfrage wird noch
viel schwieriger werden für die politik
und für die gesellschaft also ist
überhaupt nicht leicht aber die pandemie
bekämpfung durch wegsperren zu lösen
das geht in die falsche richtung
schützen ja auch wenn wir das virus
differenzierter bekämpfen darauf hinaus
also nicht wie bisher mit dem holzhammer
alles platt hauen alles runter fahren
sondern quasi wie mit einem florett
kämpfen und gucken ob man nicht genauer
flexibler schneller dahin geht wo das
virus ist und dann wird man trotzdem die
besonderes die besonders wunder haben
gruppen sind die älteren aber natürlich
auch asthmakranke leute mit schwächerem
immunsystem das kann auch jüngere seien
besonders schützen müssen das bedeutet
immer rücksichtnahme besondere angebote
aber keinen weg sperren wie will man das
kontrollieren wie man das als
gesellschaft denken überhaupt man kann
ja nicht ein viertel oder ein drittel
der gesellschaft in isolationshaft
machen und dann kommt die polizei und
sagten sie wir mit dem mann passt zeigen
und dann auch sie sind erst mal krank
sie müssen noch ein strafmandaten machen
das funktioniert muss herr einheit
müssen die alten länger drinbleiben
damit
daraus kann also diesen begriff umkehr
isolation isolation als solches als
begriff sind finde ich extrem
unglücklich und auch falsch nachdem ich
habe gab es nur zu
der begriff cocoon im englischen ist
etwas anders als umsorgen und pflegen
umhüllen
also ich das dass man den aufwand immer
betreibt aktuell um das feststellen sind
die alten menschen haben gerade eben
darüber gesprochen
total isoliert ja das sowie was
eigentlich nicht lassen können auch da
nicht lassen können
das heißt wenn wir aufwand betreiben
wollen für die zukunft um differenziert
wie sie sagen mit dem florett fechten
dafür zu sorgen dass wir etwas
intelligentes tun was auf der basis von
fakten die wir vielleicht zwischenzeit
erheben tatsächlich sinnvoll ist dann
müssen wir glaube ich schon ältere
menschen nicht isolieren aber bild
schützen oder behüten und das hat dann
an andere bedeutung als sie wegzusperren
das bedeutet dann schon dass der umgang
für sie kompliziert bleibt und auch
etwas anders organisiert werden muss als
wenn man völlig frei einkaufen geht oder
alles tut was man sonst auch gut aber
das kann man auf eine menschlich den
aufwand den man antrag nicht mehr
betreiben muss setzt ja vielleicht auch
kraftvoll in da etwas differenziert und
intelligent ein zu sind uns einig dass
es besser umgezogen und einsperren oder
der glaube was mache ich bloß in diesen
unterschied dass das ist was ganz andere
ist zwei punkte über dem aspekt muss man
es betreiben aber besonderen schutz
bedürfen sie das steht sicher fest frau
gitta jetzt haben wir eine
parteifreundin von ihnen zitiert die
berliner gesundheitsministerin die
menschen über 70 unter quarantäne
stellen möchte was antworten sie ihre
sorgen sie ihr ich glaube dass eine
zweiklassengesellschaft nach dem motto
die einen dürfen raus die anderen müssen
drin bleiben dass das nicht
funktionieren kann und ich finde auch so
eine grenzziehung am lebensalter wir
müssen feststellen und es ist für mich
eine selbstverständlichkeit auch ältere
menschen sind mündige bürger es gibt
unterschiedlich 70 jährige ja es gibt
die die treiben jeden tag sport und sind
total fit und es gibt 50 jährige die
haben schon ganz ganz viele
gesundheitliche probleme wie will man
denn da die grenze ziehen ich glaube
nicht dass wir damit gut das ganze
managen können
das geht nicht und wir müssen es
schaffen dass wir natürlich gucken wie
wir differenziert daran gehen und wie
wir auch schaffen das eben diejenigen
die besonders gefährdet sind einen
besonderen schutz erfahren aber nicht
sozusagen eine eine pauschale antwort
geben die hatten nicht gefasst ist auch
je nicht eine pauschale antwort geben
dass eben ältere persönlich raus dürfen
dann dass das ist aus meiner sicht nicht
durchsetzbar nicht umsetzbar und auch
nicht wünschenswert und deshalb müssen
andere möglichkeiten überlegt werden so
und frau und die frage ist in ihren
augen nicht total erstaunlich wie viel
solidarität in der bevölkerung gibt
gerade mit den risikopatienten und den
alten menschen
also ich muss sagen solidarität geht
erleben auch durch die umwelt durch die
gesellschaft indem sie uns wahrnehmen in
gegen sich für uns klatschen das ist
schön
sogar der bundestages aufgestanden
vielen dank aber indem sie das gemacht
haben denke ich mir dass sie auch nicht
dagegen sind dass wir eine bessere
bezahlung haben das haben wir damit auch
eingeräumt
das sehe ich als eine anerkennung aber
wissen sie wir haben keine zeit mehr zu
verhandeln
die pflegekräfte gehen sie flüchten weil
die schlechte arbeitsbedingungen haben
ein verdammt schlechter bezahlen und
ganz miese bezahlung wir sind hoch gut
ausgebildet und wir sind wichtig für
diese menschen
es ist ein unterschied ob ich sie jetzt
mittel oder beschäftige wir sind dafür
ausgebildet diese menschen adäquat zu
begleiten
die alten menschen sind keine menschen
die getötet werden wollen die brauchen
hochqualifiziertes personal diese gesund
erhalten die wir schützen diese menschen
und wenn wir jetzt noch das hoch
qualifizierte personal was überhaupt
noch vielen dank überhaupt noch kommt
dann müssen wir schauen dass wir die
nicht auch noch verlieren und jetzt
überlegt sich schon wieder eine pflege
gruppe dass sie nach diesem chor ohne
virus gehen weil sie das nicht mehr
mitmachen und wertschätzung ist und
bleibt auch monetär und 4000 euro
bruttogehalt finde ich einen
angemessenen einstiegsgehalt für uns
also ich sehe noch mal einfach ganz klar
sagen da wird nicht irgendwas verhandelt
sondern im letzten jahr
sicher die bundesvereinigung der
arbeitgeber in der pflegebranche
gegründet die gerade mit verdi bis zum
mai einen tarifvertrag aushandeln bis
zum mai diesen jahres und dieser
tarifvertrag wir haben ja noch nicht das
ergebnis also wenn sie jetzt schon sagen
es reicht nicht zu sagen
ich sag mal so jetzt müssen doch
diejenigen die diesen tarifvertrag
aushandeln sich wirklich noch mal auch
angesichts der aktuellen lage überlegen
was ist der richtige wert was ist die
richtige entscheidung das muss jetzt
passieren und dann ist ja dieser
tarifvertrag der verabschiedet wird auch
die möglichkeit für hubertus heil
unseren arbeitsminister zu sagen und das
erkläre ich als allgemeinverbindlich für
die ganze bundesrepublik gültig und da
muss man hinkommt wir haben in der
pflege doch nur 20 prozent derjenigen
die nach tariflichen bedingungen
arbeiten 80 prozent tun es nicht
und das ist doch die problematik wir
müssen zur richtigen tarifen
einmalzahlungen sind nett da bin ich
völlig bei ihnen aber wir müssen zu
einer strukturellen veränderung
aufwertung der berufe kommen und das
geht nur durch eine viel stärkere
tarifliche bindung es sind ja die
mindest lohnerhöhungen sind ja
beschlossen worden
das kommt auch aber das ist ja die
mindestgrenze die muss natürlich höher
werden dadurch dass tarife vereinbart
werden die demnach kommen was sie sich
wünschen und dafür ist es nötig dass die
arbeitgeber das die gewerkschaften jetzt
auch einen entsprechenden beschluss
fassen damit das für das ganze
bundesgebiet verbindlich erklärt werden
kann das kann der arbeitsminister das
will er wir sind im ganz engen austausch
dazu und ich wünsche mir dass das klappt
und dass auch diese krise vielleicht ein
1 1 punkt ist an dem da jetzt auch noch
einmal neue bewegung und neue kraft rein
geht damit tatsächlich dann auch 80
prozent die jetzt noch nicht nach
tarifvertrag bezahlt werden mit einem
besseren lohn rechnen können wir sind an
dieser stelle an der wir gerne mit ihnen
nochmal auf die zahlen schauen wollen
weil ob und wann wir in unserer
gesellschaft irgendwie auf dem klavier
auch wieder eine weiße taste anklingen
und anschlagen können natürlich davon
abhängt ob sich und wie schnell sich
etwas an den zahlen verändert und das
ist der jüngste standen
anfang märz hat sich die infizierten
zahl in deutschland noch alle 48 stunden
verdoppelt
jetzt sieht man erste erfolge der
getroffenen maßnahmen die verdopplung
zeit wird länger
die aktuelle zahl der bestätigten
neuinfektionen beträgt 24 1900 durch die
verdopplung erfolgt erst nach 96 tagen
keine entwarnung aber ein
hoffnungsschimmer und in bonn begrüße
ich jetzt den biologen professor hendrik
strikt herrschte keinen guten abend zu
ihnen wie interpretieren sie diese
zahlen ist das eine momentaufnahme oder
dürfen geholfen einen schönen namen frau
illner
natürlich macht es schon erstmal
hoffnung eine verlangsamung zu sehen
aber man muss das jetzt noch mal ein
paar tage erstmal beobachten weil dir
immer natürlich auch zum wochenende
einen major effekt sehen also dass über
das wochenende natürlich keine
neuinfektionen gemeldet werden und wir
dadurch auch nicht genau sagen können
wie sich jetzt in den letzten tagen
verhalten hat aber sieht erstmal gut aus
wir kommen zu ihrer arbeit sie
untersuchen gerade präzise in heinsberg
also in einem dieser cluster wie sich da
die infektion ausgebreitet hat damit wir
zu endlich validen zahlen kommen herr
professor strick oder was ist das ziel
ihrer studie
ja ich glaube was die menschen brauchen
ist nicht meinungen oder spekulationen
sondern sie braucht wissenschaftlich
fundierte fakten und wir haben die
chance in diesem jahr miniatur
deutschland in gangelt im kreis
heinsberg wo wir sehr viele infektionen
gesehen haben aber viele todesfälle
wir haben ja auch die chance für
deutschland zu verstehen wie hoch die
dunkelziffer ist also wie viele menschen
eigentlich infiziert sind ohne dass sie
davon wissen
wir können sehen weil die ein paar tage
im vor paar wochen im voraus die
infektion schon hatten können wir sehen
ob bestimmte maßnahmen die ergriffen
wurden funktioniert haben und wir können
auch besser verstehen wie die
ausbreitungsweg funktionieren zum
beispiel in zusammenarbeit mit der
hygiene mit herrn professor exner und
frau doktor doktor schmidt hausen
versuchen wir zu verstehen wo sich das
virus über alle aufhält und ob wir dann
geben sie uns die abstriche ob wir
dieses virus dann noch an züchten können
im labor alles wichtige fragen die uns
jetzt der ministerpräsident laschet den
auftrag für erteilt hat um das zur
erforschung möglichst schnell fakten zu
liefern damit die politik auf deren
basis auch entscheidungen treffen kann
und man hätte im grunde mit ihrer studie
dann auch die möglichkeit zu sehen
welche lockerung welcher dieser
maßnahmen was mit der infektionszahlen
machen
theoretisch ja und das ist natürlich für
einen biologen die mich ein
favorisiertes modell aber ein bieres
gehört da nicht sofort ist er die
inkubationszeit dauert mehrere tage
und wenn wir das wirklich an denken
würden dass wir ja gangelt als beispiel
nehmen um langfristig zu sehen die sich
das verändert hätten wir das problem
dass wir noch mal längere wochen im
anderen im rest von deutschland quasi
warten müssen bis wir diesen effekt
beobachtet haben und ich glaube so lange
will die politik wahrscheinlich nicht
warten als geologe wie mich wäre das
natürlich ein ein spannendes experiment
klar darüber werden wir gleich noch mal
diskutieren wichtige frage an sie er
strikt ist natürlich auch haben sie
ideen gibt es ideen wie man gerade in
krankenhäusern gerade in altenheimen den
kontakt zu den älteren menschen eben
wieder möglich machen könnte wie man da
ein bisschen mehr freiheit und ein
bisschen mehr menschlichkeit angehörige
haben wir diskutiert
wieder zu den alten menschen kommen
lassen kann ja ja ich sehe auch da ein
ethisches dilemma auf der einen seite
natürlich wenn man als bürger spricht
finde ich das schon schwere maßnahmen
geführt vor allem alte die mit
einsamkeit sowieso zu kämpfen haben
auf der anderen seite und das hat ja
doktor rhein hat wirklich gut formuliert
man muss diese person ganz besonders
beschützen und biologen und die
epidemiologen und hygieniker wir müssen
ideen kreative lösungen finden wie wir
die am besten schützen können
passiert jetzt ausprobieren in meinem im
kreiskrankenhaus und heinsberg ist
erstmal das personal jede woche in einer
pool testung zu testen um zu sehen dass
nicht das virus von den angestellten
weiter gegeben also die mitarbeitern das
krankenhaus weiter gegeben werden kann
eine andere möglichkeit wäre mit diesem
molekularen schnelltests die von er wird
zum beispiel die alle fünf innerhalb von
fünf minuten 20 minuten ein schnelles
ergebnis zeigen mit diesen quasi eine
eingangs voraussetzungen zu schaffen
dass jeder der drei in das heim reingeht
vorher getestet wird ob das funktioniert
das müssen aber pilotstudien wieder
zeigen und das kann man nicht einfach so
entscheiden wie lange brauchen diese
molekularen tests um nach deutschland
geführt um zu kommen das heißt wann gibt
es die möglichkeit dazu so einen
schnelltest zu machen wir versuchen
händeringend unsere hände danach dazu zu
kriegen
das hat das ausprobieren können leider
hatten wir bisher kein glück ich glaube
aber solche wege werden die besten wege
um auf der einen seite wirklich die
bedürftigen zu schützen und auf der
anderen seite sie aber auch vor
einsamkeit zu geschützt absolut
professor strikt das sind interessante
ideen und natürlich wichtige und vor
allen dingen welche die hoffnung machen
vielen herzlichen dank danke und einen
guten abend zu ihnen nach bonn frau
urlaub würde das schon
helfen wenn man tatsächlich mit solchen
schnelltests möglich machen würde dass
angehörige wieder in die heime kommen
können sicher das würde ganz viel helfen
immer muss auch dass viele kriegen doch
gar keine besucher also sind auch
wirklich leute sind auf uns angewiesen
dass wir sie also quad beschäftigen die
die angehörige haben es sind die
wenigsten
die haben doch glück gehabt aber das
wäre natürlich eine ganz tolle lösung
dass wir den schritt entgegen nehmen was
aber nicht die qualität und einen
fachkräften besetzt und damit sind wir
noch mal robert habeck bei der frage
nicht über das wan zu diskutieren an dem
wir dann nach dem 19 vierten irgendwie
über eine lockerung nachdenken sondern
wie das aussehen könnte
es gibt viele virologen es gibt schlaue
ethiker die dazu natürlich auch schon
papiere entwerfen und einen
ideenwettbewerb ausrufen
man könnte die schulen für die
oberschüler an manchen tagen öffnen man
könnte die grundschüler an den anderen
tagen reinlassen man könnte überlegen
vielleicht doch friseure wieder möglich
zu machen weil es bis dato da relativ
wenig infektionen gibt hat auch herr
strikt herausgefunden wie glauben sie
kann und wird man darauf spielen nochmal
auf diesem klavier
also wenn wir uns einig sind dass diese
maßnahme ich glaube das ist der konsens
im moment in der gesellschaft und in der
politik erst einmal als sofortmaßnahmen
notwendig waren aber natürlich extreme
herten in jedem bereich auslösen und
nicht grenzenlos fortgesetzt werden
können weil irgendwann einfach eine
gesellschaft auseinanderfliegt dadurch
im sozialen bereich im wirtschaftlichen
bereich und beides ist habe ich mehr
miteinander auch verknüpft dann ist ja
nicht die alternative so weiter wie
vorher und die zur schönen gezeigte
kurve geht auf einmal wieder durch die
decke oder im detail fällt sie ab und
die die inkubationszeit verdoppelt sich
wieder alle zwei tage noch eben weiter
wie bisher also muss es einen dritten
weg geben und der dritte weg so verstehe
ich die debatte und die verschiedenen
initiativen von landes- und bundesebene
bedeutet testen testen testen dass man
weiß wo das virus ist dann schnell die
kontakten und infektionswege
nachzeichnen dass wir über
über die immer gesprochen wird möglich
wären auswahl für die ich wäre unter
bestimmten bedingungen an unternehmen
weiter hat sich entspannen bei allem was
wir so gemeinsam machen am anfang
verlaufen und jetzt ist es ganz gut
jetzt läuft es auf die richtige auf die
richtige programmierung diaz daten und
bürgerschutz rechtlich in ordnung hinaus
müsste es aber auch bald kommen das ding
mir wenn wir nach einem 19 damit
arbeiten wollen dann müssen die
einführung jetzt in der nächsten woche
auf dem markt sein ich hoffe dass das
auch funktionieren kann ich weiß dass
daran gearbeitet wird und das ist
bestimmt alles viel komplizierter als
man das nicht so als laie denkt aber ist
muss jetzt in die gänge gekommen das
würde helfen dritten es natürlich die
hygienemaßnahmen inklusive mundschutz
aufrecht zu erhalten
und viertens teams aufstellen die dann
das ganze zusammen führen also die task
force die in den gesundheitsämtern in
den laboren überwachen ob die
informationen auch laufen aber das muss
man klar sagen das ist ein dass es
abstrakt formuliert und das risiko für
die politik ist dass es schief geht und
dass deswegen ist das eine ganz heikle
geschichte dass es im gewissen sinne
auch wenn es fast zynisch klingt viel
leichter maßnahmen auch noch mögen sie
noch so drakonisch ein zu beschließen
als sie wieder zurückzunehmen weil
danach die bundeskanzlerin hat das ja
gesagt jedes menschenleben zählt immer
wenn dann irgendwas nicht funktioniert
ist die gefahr dass man sagt das war
mein menschenleben das war das leben
meiner mutter meines vaters und so
weiter also deswegen ist lanz ich sage
ja alles schon
wir stoßen jetzt erst in den bereich der
schwierige abwägungsfrage vor
trotzdem glaube ich daran muss
gearbeitet werden und die
bundesregierung wäre gut beraten den
arbeitsprozess auf transparenz zu machen
damit es eine hoffnung gibt wohin die
reise gehen kann also das höre ich noch
mal eine leichte kritik heraus auch
helge braun hat letzten donnerstag mit
uns diskutiert und hat natürlich auch
gesagt irgendwann müssen wir wieder
lockern und wir können nicht allen
menschen in diesem land zumuten jetzt
quasi unter quarantäne zu sein oder
wenigstens die content lennestadt den
schmalen grat für entscheidungsträger ja
von von von ministerpräsidenten
bundeskanzler gesundheitsministern
erwartet man dass sie sagen was ist und
nicht was war im konjunktiv was könnte
sein und trotzdem zu sagen ihr dürft
nicht diskutieren und wir lassen das
allen anderen das ist nicht gut das das
ich sag's mal positiv ich glaube dass
wir als gesellschaft im moment zu einem
großen konsens haben weil es gelungen
ist einen fehler toleranz einzuräumen
weil die bundeskanzlerin gesagt hat wir
sind hier auf neuland wir wissen vieles
nicht wir müssen ist probieren aber
besser vorsicht ist die mutter der
porzellankiste und da sind alle
eingestiegen
und ich glaube man hält den konsens am
ehesten wenn man genau den schmalen grat
findet zwischen wir wollen nicht
spekulieren aber wir lassen uns in die
karten gucken damit nicht
verschwörungstheorien und sowie die
maizière ja wenn sie wüssten dass ich
weiß könntest denn beunruhigen das ist
schon mal schief
das sollte nicht einhalten na ja man
möchte schon verstehen was nach dem 19
04 passiert und man möchte eben nicht da
sein kann hier aus dem innenminister
dann an die öffentlich aus dem
innenministerium an die öffentlichkeit
kommen und alle sich fragen was ist denn
das jetzt mit einem worst-case-szenario
ja also ist die möglichkeit da frau
gefahr dass man tatsächlich sagt wir
können euch noch nicht sagen wann aber
es ist total schlau darüber nachzudenken
auch das hat die ethikerin angeboten
dass wir eben nicht nur nach
risikogruppen schauen sondern auch nach
regionen unterschiedlich also kann man
vielleicht in meck kommen viel früher
über eine öffnung von schulen nachdenken
als jetzt in nordrhein westfalen
genau diese sachen werden jetzt auch
diskutiert es gibt der verabredete
gespräche auch mit den bundesländern und
wir müssen uns für jeden einzelnen
bereich genau darüber gedanken wie man
zurückfinden kann in die normalität
nicht zu früh aber auch nicht zu spät
und das ist ein schmaler grat natürlich
aber es geht schon auch darum es ist
weiter notwendig den gesundheitsschutz
an erster stelle zustand aber auch
risiken und nebenwirkungen abwägen all
das andere auch mit einzubeziehen und
dann einen dritten weg zu gehen da kann
ich ihnen zustimmen ich glaube das sind
jetzt die nächsten schritte aber erst
mal war es sehr sehr wichtig auch in
dieser konsequenz in dieser
schnelligkeit mit diesem riesen
hilfspaket was einzigartig in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik auch diese
dinge zu tun um eben
zu und die verbreitung zu verlangsamen
da müssen wir uns immer wieder zurück
besinnt dass bei der sinn und dass es
gemacht worden ist ihre befürchtung auch
herein hat dass wir tatsächlich mit
unterschiedlichen verboten gegenüber
unterschiedlichen regionen oder menschen
diese situation und solidarität die wir
jetzt haben verlieren oder glauben sie
dass das für die hoffnung und für das
verständnis der leute wichtig ist zu
sagen wir muten euch dass nur eine
bestimmte zeit zu für keinen ist das
schön keiner will das und da und darüber
denkt männer
ich glaube man das offen tod darüber
nachzudenken erstens und zweitens will
man das nachdenken nicht nur der politik
egal ist sondern wenn man sozusagen den
kreis derjenigen die man da einbezieht
großmacht und die kompetenz die dort
vertreten ist zahlreich und daraus dann
eine entscheidung fällt von der alle
wissen dass diese entscheidung eine
hypothese ist weil wir nur mit hypothese
arbeiten können die auch risiken
beinhaltet
wenn wir das alles wissen und auch
vernünftig kommunizieren glaube ich
bleib die solidarität erhalten
vielleicht erlauben sie noch eine
bemerkung in dem kontext jedes einzelne
leben zählt selbstverständlich
nichtsdestotrotz muss man sagen ist das
was wir aktuell auch in der bewertung
allgemein erleben von corona drängt hier
alles andere völlig in den hintergrund
und wenn wir es schon sagen jedes
einzelne leben zählt dann müssen wir die
einzelnen leben dann die jetzt aktuell
unter der gesamtsituation corona leiden
eigentlich sozusagen dagegen rechnen
und das tun wir natürlich auch nicht das
können wir auch geist theo ist reine
theorie
aber wir sollten diese theorie wir sind
theoretischen ansatz im kopf behalten
wenn wir uns zur politischen
entscheidung am schluss durchringen
diesen dritten weg nehmen sie eben mit
den details die sie offiziell völlig
richtig skizziert haben gehen und auch
mit einer existenznot frau gefällt kann
man menschen natürlich krank machen man
kann sie auch mit dem nicht arbeiten
können krank machen und gegebenenfalls
töten
sie kümmern sich natürlich sehr um die
prekären verhältnisse in den familien
sie haben das vorhin schon angedeutet
eine ganz praktische frage müsste man
nicht tatsächlich in diese notbetreuung
der kindergärten auch die hat vier
kinder aufnehmen also kinder die aus
prekären verhältnissen
die gelten jetzt nur nur zur erklärung
für menschen die in den sogenannten
systemrelevanten aber tätig sind
muss da nicht auch ein kind aus einer
prekären familie rein
das hängt davon ab wie lange das jetzt
geht wir sehen aber dass wir eine
zunahme haben an häuslicher gewalt auch
einen konfliktsituationen in der kinder
und jugendhilfe ist das sichtbar und
auch bei fragen von sexuellem
kindesmissbrauch müssen wir leider davon
ausgehen dass die zahl der fälle steigt
und die kinder haben dann eben in dieser
situation nicht die möglichkeit sich
hilfe zu holen weil sie ja im häuslichen
bleiben und das ist eine situation die
ist sehr sehr schwierig und deshalb muss
man sich überlegen wie man auch
notbetreuung dann realisiert ich finde
aber schwierig auch dazusagen pauschal
alle hat vier kinder sind haben quasi
dann gewalt sieht es heute ist und das
ist so nicht sondern wir sehen das
gerade fälle von kindesmissbrauch usw
durch alle schichten gehen dass wir auch
jetzt eine situation in den familien
haben mit der keiner so umgehen kann und
vorbereitet ist und deshalb ist wirklich
die frage wer geht dann auch wieder in
die normalität zurück ich denke dass wir
einen bestimmten stellen die
notbetreuung auch aus werden könnten das
hängt aber davon ab wann die schulen
generell wieder öffnen
und natürlich ist das etwas was zu sehr
viel normalität beitragen würde wenn
kitas und schulen wieder öffnen und man
vielleicht nach so einem modell die
oberschüler können wieder rein oder die
grundschule und an verschiedenen tagen
was muss man gut überlegen wie man leute
in kategorien sortieren ich finde und
das ist schwieriger da hat robert habeck
sicherlich recht im nachhinein diese
differenzierenden maßnahmen zu fällen
als erstmal für alle zu sagen wir müssen
uns alle schützen
eine infizierung nach einer aufgehobenen
maßnahme
da wird anders beurteilt werden juni
wieder hochfahren
und gerade von wer hat schuld und das
ist für eine moralische frage keine
keine normative frage die wird sofort
oder wird leichter gestellt werden und
das wissen auch alle ich bin das ist ja
nicht so dass im kanzleramt oder in den
staatskanzleien nicht diskutiert werden
oder es ist eben nicht zum dritten mal
das ist eben es wird jetzt wird es erst
richtig kompliziert es gibt auch leute
die stelle jetzt die frage ob die das
aufrechterhalten der aktuellen shutdowns
in der gleichen dimension nicht andere
schädigt unangemessen schädigt also das
muss auch gesprochen und auch gewogen
werden
2,6 millionen menschen ältere menschen
werden zu hause gepflegt wir haben
vorhin schon darüber gesprochen wie man
vielleicht mit zusätzlichen menschen
auch helfen kann die eben beispielsweise
die bufdis 7 irgendwie ihr soziales jahr
bei älteren machen und das wäre dann
auch eine große hilfe und unterstützung
wie viel sorge haben sie dass das
tatsächlich einen auch für sie ein immer
größeres risiko wird ihren job zu machen
ihre arbeit zu machen
also ich muss meine erste sorge gilt
wirklich den alten menschen in den
pflegeheimen wenn wir zusätzlich leute
kriegen die besuchsdienste machen oder
sonst was wir können gar nicht mehr
darauf verzichten
aber was mir wirklich kopfschmerzen
macht ist dadurch dass wir zu wenig
professionelles personal haben die leute
sterben nicht alle einem corona virus
nicht abend auch ein schlechter pflege
und wir leisten im moment schlechte
pflege wir können nicht sagen wenn ich
keine schutzkleidung hat oder ich habe
keine professionelle begleitung wenn
jeder alles machen darf daran sterben
menschen wir sind so ausgebildet dass
wir auch prophylaxe für diese alten
leute haben das ist die fürsorge die wir
leisten und die sehe ich immer weiter
schwinden und das können diese leute uns
nicht abnehmen was uns wirklich abnehmen
können ist die einsamkeit der alten
menschen zu lindern und das darf man
nicht wegreden
das darf man auch nicht unterschätzen
weil auf der heide fahren natürlich sehr
helfen
ich darf mich bei ihnen allen bedanken
keine leichte diskussion und es war gut
dass sie sich alle auch diese
schwierigen gedanken mit uns gemacht
haben eine generation kann immer von
einer anderen generation lernen
das sagt eine ehemalige
grundschullehrerin und
kommunalpolitikerinnen aus der pfalz sie
ist 101 jahre und ihr möchte ich gerne
das schlusswort zu dieser sendung lassen
vorher wünsche ich ihnen sehr besondere
ostern dann doch irgendwie einigermaßen
gute feiertage wenn sie möchten sehen
wir uns mitte april wieder am 16 04
und hier sind die wichtigen sätze von
liesel heise scheinbar muss der mensch
hat und zum vom die begrüßung haben wir
den schacht und da kann man jetzt bloß
hoffen dass diese menschen notlage den
menschen schon wieder mehr zurück führt
zudem werden die wirklich notwendig sind
dazu
[Musik]